- So, Lamorne, you're from Chicago.
Do you ever get back
there to see your mom?
- I do, I do.
I try to get back a couple times a year,
when things aren't so busy.
My mom is like my favorite.
- Aww!
- Yeah, she's the greatest human.
- I hope my son says that!
- Yeah, well, you know.
My mom is the best though.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
She's better than everybody's mom.
- [Kelly] I love that!
Why is she the best?
- She does things like...
I grew up to be a comedic
actor and performer,
and I had no idea that my mom was funny
until she started prank phone calling me.
- [Kelly] Prank phone calling?
- I would go home to visit my mom,
and my old bedroom is
right next door to hers,
and so I would get a phone call
with her name on it,
and it would go, "Hello?"
- (laughs) What?
- Mom, what are you doing?
"How do you know it's me?"
(audience laughing)
It's the future, mom.
We've got caller ID now.
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah, that's how my mom is.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.